i'm fine i'm good we're
getting a little bit hungover people are
getting tired
and this is the time that i would like
to ask everybody to
realize that it isn't just it didn't not
end or slowed down it got worse in
ukraine
maxim schmerkovsky returns to europe to
help ukraine as russia continues
invading his home country
e.t learned on sunday that max left l.a
and is now in poland helping with
ukrainian refugee relief efforts we've
been working we've been working on
you know tangible opportunities to help
the dancing with the stars alum took to
instagram live to share an update
revealing he started his own
humanitarian fund we've started our
organization veronova 27 but on over 27
is the address where
our father myself and val
were born in addis in ukraine
so that's where sort of our roots are at
we've been working diligently on
making barn over 27 something that
as big as it took off
that can continue that way i'm
here in poland as part of figuring out
how to
manage this middle part as well and so
we're trying to be a bigger presence
we're trying to figure out how to be
present here on the ground
before concluding the live video max
shares another plea for ukraine
humanitarian crisis is getting worse
people are getting hurt worse there are
more people hurt
and there are more people affected
i would really really like for you guys
to
give yourself a day off
tune out
go to church spend time with your family
do your thing but please come back to us
and come back to realization that a lot
of people still need our help as for
max's wife peta murgatroyd she shared
that she's already missing her husband
posting this photo of him with their
five-year-old son shy
welcome back how does it feel
the dancer made his emotional return
back to the u.s on march 2nd after being
stuck in the country for over a week
following russia's invasion
i'm on a station about 20 30 40 i don't
actually know where i'm at but like 30
minutes before the polish border they
stopped to change wheels
on the train
that can make this up max finally made
it home to los angeles international
airport where he was greeted by his wife
max what does it mean to be home
i just don't want to present peace
somewhere else because of what i just
saw and that's that's the reality to
understand how that works but
i don't know
what to say
at the time a source told et that peta
is so thrilled to have max home and back
with her and their son she's been going
through it and has been worried sick and
emotional the source added that the
couple is incredibly grateful for the
outpouring of support they received from
friends fans and their dancing with the
stars family i appreciate you all beyond
imagination and thank you all so much
[Music]
you